Hey, good afternoon, everyone.
Almost the end of the conference.
It's uh how's everyone doing?
Uh, still surviving,
uh. All
right, you know, so today in this session, we're gonna talk
about harness, who harness is, what we do.
Uh, and we have, will, uh, have
a fireside chat, uh, with Marriott,
one of the customers of Harness, and how Marriott
has transformed their
DevOps and their software engineering, uh,
using Harness.
So I'll, I'll start with, uh,
you know, uh, introducing Who Harness is,
uh, our mission in harness that
we have all the developers, software engineers in the world
writing a lot of code, writing much more code now with
AI. How do we enable them to ship
all that code very quickly, reliably, uh,
efficiently,
uh, and securely.
And but if you look at like, you know, what's happening
with AI, it's the biggest, uh,
conversation everywhere in the world of software engineering is AI.
Uh, a lot of the focus is AI on coding,
uh, and
everyone has adopted in one way or another. Uh,
everyone is using it either through your business, you're
using it personally,
white coding, uh, AI agents for coding,
uh, which is really powerful.
But if you look at these numbers from, uh, from
Google's Dora Research,
25% increase in code volume, uh,
using AI.
But there is a 7.2%
decrease in the in the
in the delivery stability and 1.5%
decrease in the delivery throughput. So why, why
is that happening? Like you're writing more code. Everyone
would think, you know, if you write more code, you're
gonna ship much more code, uh,
but that's not really happening. A big part of
that is
coding is not everything, uh, you know,
that you do as software engineering.
The inner loop of software engineering that you spec
something and you write code, that's only the 1st
30-40% of the time that the engineering team will
do. Then you give it to the outer loop,
you know, when it goes out of the developer's laptop, that's
at least 60-70% of the time,
uh, that you spend doing all kinds of things from, you
know, testing, securing, deploying, optimizing.
And if you look at in those buckets, the testing, securing
deploying, optimize,
there's so many workflows you have to do. Like if you
just look at testing, unit testing, integration
testing, load testing, resiliency testing,
API testing, UI testing.
If you look at your security, you
have the code security scans, API security
scans, supply chains scans,
audit approvals, governance approvals.
Checks if you look at what
you have to do for deployment, code deployment,
feature flags,
database deployments, infrastructure,
infrastructure as code, infrastructure changes, artifact
management, you know, and then you have
to optimize it all the cost of the cloud, cost of
AI, cost of data,
you know, cost of your, you know, your teams and processes.
That's where a lot of the software engineering
time goes, 60 to 70% of the time.
You know, you see, you saw all these, you know, workflows
that historically have been a big painful
process for people to do, like, you know,
everything, these 30 plus complex workflows.
With AI,
the, the code volume is going up. There's 4X
more code volume there, you know, in many companies, you
know, you see 20 to 25% pretty often,
uh, but we're gonna very soon be in at least
in 4X.
But if you don't have the downstream outer loop
optimized,
we don't,
we're not going to get the throughput out of it.
And that's where if you look at the testing
processes, a lot of manual steps.
The security is mostly siloed away
from DevOps and the deployment systems.
Deployments are mostly still
written through scripting.
People, you take your CI
from the old kind of CIs and
add deployment scripting on top of it
and optimization.
A lot of people still have a lot of inefficiencies
you see everywhere from cloud costs, all
kinds of costs that are happening everywhere.
That's what Harness is looking to solve.
Harness is a platform for software delivery
and bringing AI and automation to the entire software
delivery process.
So Harness is built of many
modules, modules to help you through
all of that process. So you use
AI to help write code better,
code faster,
and be much more efficient in coding.
And harness becomes the automation and AI
solution to help you after that,
which is, you know, increase your velocity, next
generation CICD,
uh, you know, next generation infrastructure as code,
uh, database DevOps, artifact registry,
you know, cloud developer environments, all kinds of
things that you need to do to modernize your DevOps
practices that you know, so that you can. Ship the
code really, really fast,
uh, you know, all the software for
uh for you know for reliability to increase the reliability
whether it's feature flags and future experimentation,
uh, chaos engineering, AI SRE,
uh, you know, AI test automation so you can replace
your selenium and playwrights and all those kind of
scripting with with AI agents are
doing the testing.
Uh, security work, uh, a lot of the app
security, uh, work that you have to do on
code security scans, API security,
supply chain security,
and then, you know, uh, optimizing it all, you
know, from your cloud cost, and then you,
you have the, uh, the engineering metrics, uh,
you know, to, uh, uh, to understand
where the inefficiencies are,
uh, you know, where, where in your engineering processes,
where the cost inefficiencies are, so
you can, you can, you can increase that.
So harness platform, you know, it's a platform of all of
these capabilities our customer.
will normally pick and choose where they want to
start with. Most of our customers
start by modernizing their CICD,
uh, you know, replacing the old CICD system
so you can have fully, fully automated process of,
uh, of, you know, code,
developer rights code, and every,
every, every, every check, every test,
every control, every,
uh, you know, check and balance is all fully automated
in the CICD pipelines, you know,
then you, then our customers start adding, you know, security
testing, resilience testing. Testing
finops, uh,
all kinds of other practices in these modern pipelines
so you can have a fully automated process, uh, uh,
you know, and get significant productivity boost,
uh, boost of, uh, by in, in doing this.
All of this, uh, uh, uses an underlying
AI foundation, you know, this, which is, uh,
uh, you know, built of a few areas, you know,
number one is the AI agents,
uh, so we have a whole library of AI agents from, uh,
to do all these tasks,
AI agents to do DevOps tasks, you know, create CICD
pipelines, you know, troubleshoot. Deployment
failure, a build failure,
you know, set up policies
around our governance policies, templates,
you know, release agents to make sure
like you know you can have the future experiments and the future releases
and the rollouts set up properly,
reliability testing, you know, UI
testing, security. So these agents
are doing all the all the work that you would
do normally through a lot of manual
dev ops kind of work to set up, set
up your set up your STLC practices.
But the agents are, you know, as I'm sure in the, the
whole conference you've heard about a lot about the context,
uh, engineering, um, but that's a, uh,
that's a very important part of, uh, what we provide
like that's the your businesses,
your enterprises have a lot of context,
context around like, you know, uh, how your
services work. How your environments work, which infrastructure
you're running on, what your security policies are, what
tests you do, how your team structure look like.
There are all kinds of things that you have to do, uh, uh, uh, uh, you know, always,
and that's what we're capturing in, in a knowledge
graph that we, we understand the knowledge graph of,
of, of, uh, any organization,
any software engineering team, where all the things are,
and that knowledge graph
is the context that, you know, how the AI agents
will use to, to do something. So for example, if we
go to our AI,
say create me a CICD pipeline for,
you know, my deployment.
Now it's like, you know,
if you, if you just create a generic stuff like if you
go to chat GPD you're gonna see a generic some
answers there.
That's not useful for any organization, any enterprise.
So that's where the context comes in. Like, you know,
in the context we understand like what does it mean?
What does your deployment policies mean? What are your
templates, what your security controls are,
what infrastructure you're running on,
what are your requirements that you need to, to run there,
you know, how, uh,
where, where things are connected with each other,
what secret systems you use,
all of that's,
you know, part of the context that we'll, that we'll use to, to
set up things.
And then we have the underlying orchestration layer,
uh, you know, these, everything. The AI agents are
doing the orchestration layer is
still, you know, could still be deterministic
around it so you can control what
you want AI agents to do. You want AI agents to
go and do a deployment in production, or
you want for them to create a pipeline
that will more deterministically do a deployment
in production. So you have the full, full
spectrum of how much
control AI takes over and how much,
you know, your, your deterministic automation
takes over, and that's what you know will
allow you to do.
We have about 1,000+ enterprise customers using
harness in, you know, in big ways
to solve these problems, uh,
you know, you'll see a lot of logos here,
you know, a lot of large banks, large technology companies,
insurance companies, airlines, you know, hospitality
companies,
you'll hear from uh from Marriott soon
here. And
we are doing it at a very large scale.
Just in the last 12 months on harness Platform,
there were 128 million deployments
that happened through Harness Platform.
We had 81 million builds that happened through Harness Platform.
11 billion tests we optimized
through our AI-based test optimization.
$1.2 trillion 1.2 trillion
API calls we watched and secured,
you know, $14 trillion feature flag evaluations,
5 million security scans,
$1.9 billion of cloud. Cost optimized
and a lot of people using the, you know, these
agents to do, do, do, uh, do these
tasks now,
uh, so we're very, uh, uh, uh, you
know, very proud, uh, that we were able to solve
these problems for many organizations and, uh,
uh, you're we're recognized, uh,
by Gartner and Forrester and as the leaders,
uh, you know, in the Gartner Magic Quadrant
for DevOps platforms. Harness is a leader,
uh, the Forester wave for DevOps platforms.
Harness is a leader now.
And we have a very strong partnership with AWS,
you know, we work very closely with AWS, uh, you
know, we, our, our everything that we do with
our AI is exposed through a lot of MCP tools
in our MCP server,
and all of those are integrated in Amazon Quiro
and, uh,
uh, you know, and, uh, any, any
kind of coding systems. We're very, uh, deep partnership with,
with, with, with Amazon.
Uh, you know, we are deployment ready on AWS,
uh, and working very closely with the
product teams and the, and the innovation, uh, as
we drive our innovation,
uh, on our knowledge graphs and our MCPs. So
if you are on AWS, which, uh, uh, you
know, we can, uh, we, we can definitely help you there. So
I'm. Going to invite our field CTO Nick
here on the stage to show you
a demo of the harness platform so you can see for
for real. And once, you know, after the demo
we'll have uh you know, uh
Adnan and Sean from from Marriott join us
and we'll have a conversation on how, how they're
using harness.
Alright,
I'm gonna try to keep this as brief but also
hopefully a little bit entertaining, give you some context.
I'm gonna show you a lot of what Harness does.
I'm not gonna talk about in the modular ways of what we're doing, but
we're gonna show you what this could look like,
um, just to give you some, some kind of ideas of how
this works. I'll show you the AI throughout this entire
process because the whole point of this is that removing
the worst part of the job,
right? If we think about where all the AI has been spent,
it's actually been the things we love doing like planning
and and then actually like critically thinking and
going through these things and developing software, but
now let's actually take away the things we hate doing, whether
it be, you know, running tests and waiting for them
to run or security. So let me walk through what this
can look like for you,
um, and how easy it is to set up and configure, but also
let's talk about. How we make this easy to
do the right thing. We want to make sure you have templates that it's
very quick and easy to get to production,
but also make sure that it's hard to do the wrong
things. And I know those are two very basic statements,
but we have to put policy in place to make sure
we're not skipping steps,
we're not combating that security scam on accident.
So making sure that we have all of the things so we know what goes into
production. Um, what you're looking at right now
is a pipeline. It's very specifically designed to go
from, uh, we've got a build stage, we're gonna do infrastructure
stand up, we're gonna deploy to multiple different environments,
and every step of the way you can see exactly what we're
doing. So anything that we're doing, it's entirely
audited. Every step of the way you can see
everything we've executed. You can see the input variables, you
can see the output variables. Everything's here for you
to know exactly what happened and how it
happened. But more importantly, what we really wanna do is
we wanna save you that time.
So one of the things you'll notice we call out really quickly is that we're saving
you about 1819 minutes' worth of time
by doing things intelligently. So for instance, if
I do a 200 line code change.
Right, I don't wanna run all 12,000
unit tests. That wouldn't necessarily make sense
because it's a very small change.
So Harness now understands exactly what's
correlated with the change that you made in the test. So
we can go ahead and correlate and understand.
Here's the uh
the changes that we made, the tests associated
with it. So now instead of running all 12,000,
I can run about 10% of those.
So right there alone saving about 8 minutes
by simply running the tests
again that are associated with the change,
right? If I have new tests, fine, I'll run those, or
if they're updated tests, I'll have to run those. I don't know how
they're going to respond,
so I need to see them. But at the end of the day, again,
take care of that pain every single build now we're
we're cutting that time away from, from your folks.
Another big one,
for folks oftentimes is dealing with security
vulnerabilities,
right? We've got tons of different scanners, so whether they're SCA
scanners, or are code scanners, whether they're
SAST, right, all the different SAST scanners,
um, you know, as you go through infrastructure scanners, so
forth, and even container scanners,
the issue is that it's very hard, it's very difficult to
go and actually get through and find
the noise throughout that or find the signal through the noise.
And so how do we start prioritizing those? How do we deduplicate
those? How do we start actually doing something that's valuable?
So one of the things that we can do for you very quickly.
Is what we'll do is we'll automatically go and aggregate,
normalize, and deduplicate all those vulnerabilities for
you. And if it's a code base, so not changing
a library, but if there's an actual code
change that needs to happen,
you know, you don't wanna see all 31 occurrences
of this sit inside of your entire environment. We can
show you them, but we wanna aggregate it. We wanna
know what's valuable to change
and then most importantly, I wanna be able to give you an AI
response of like how would we go do this.
That's fine, but in the reality today, what
would happen is somebody would go build me a spreadsheet. I'd take
that spreadsheet, I'd turn it into Jira tickets. Those Jira
tickets would go into a backlog, and two weeks later, somebody
might go fix that critical vulnerability.
And instead,
why would we do that? Why wouldn't we have Harness just go and
understand the lines of code with that knowledge graph that
Jyothi talked about? I can know the lines of
code, I know the vulnerability. I can actually
just go ahead and write you the PR.
Here's how you fix it.
So you don't have to go through the process and think about it
and go through this. These are the things we hate doing. Let's
let harness handle that portion for you,
so that you can go ahead and again do the
things that you love.
And So again, this is just in the
build phase, right? Just very simple things thinking
about things like your best engineers, taking away
all the extra work and the toil that we don't wanna go through
as this progresses forward, we're gonna build that full
bill of materials for you so you can make sure you know what's in that
artifact. You're gonna have the attestations to prove this
is that same artifact
so that you don't have an attack that they're gonna do through your supply
chain. We know this is the exact artifact. We know what it's
built, right? And so all throughout this process
only ever progressing forward,
if and only if
this actually meets those requirements.
Right, so after this one was, uh, we, we did our build,
now we're gonna go stand up some infrastructure. And so
the benefit here is we're gonna go look at that infrastructure and the
neat parts is,
is that not only do I wanna go and, and, and make the assumption
of like, OK, great, we're gonna do that plan, we're gonna that apply,
but what's it gonna cost me?
And I can actually go ahead and I can actually look
at the estimated costs in that
environment and I can go look, hey this is gonna 19x
my costs. Maybe I should pause that infrastructure
change until someone actually says and approves
that so the policy can even be on the cost
of what's changing. We wanna bring that information
now when it's valuable,
not a month later when it's sitting there running in production.
Right, as we go through this now, it's we've studied the infrastructure,
we've done the build, we've done the infrastructure.
Now I'm gonna go ahead and I'm gonna look at our uh deployments
into dev. We're going QA staging
and again following that same pipeline, being able to
see and and audit every single thing that we've done,
it's gonna go through that, making sure it's that same bill
of materials that we've got that same salsa check. It's gonna
make sure that we're
integrating with all of your ticketing systems.
So now I'm updating Jira, I'm updating Service now. I'm
putting the evidence in the places that are needed
so that I don't have to do that collection anymore,
right? Again, tasks we don't wanna do.
Um, this is gonna go through. This is gonna do that
application. It's also gonna make the database change
for you, so it's gonna roll out in a way that's meaningful, but
also a way that can roll back in the same capacity.
So we'll go ahead and roll out those database changes and
then ultimately this is just gonna roll out to, to, uh,
to, to the dev environment. We'll go do some tests.
If it's great, we'll update the tickets, right? And
we can see this thing kind of progress through.
In QA it's almost the same pipeline, but we're gonna add a whole
bunch of tests.
So we're gonna go run those tests where
our AI can actually go ahead and design
and create those tests on the fly. If I move a
button and change a button and change a color, I don't wanna go
put an X path somewhere. I can have this determine
it for me, but I can also run all the resiliency
checks throughout the process.
So now when we think about.
I wanna make sure that I've got enough replicas. I wanna
make sure that I can handle an outage. I, I'm gonna keep
my order. All of the things that I wanna prevent, I
can have those actually running as
chaos tests for us and again
only ever move forward if it meets those
requirements that I have. If it doesn't meet my resiliency requirements,
don't worry about it.
Pause the pipeline, stop,
go fix them,
right, so you can continue forward.
I'll go to one last one really quickly. I don't wanna spend too much
time. Um, and in production
we've been doing this for the last 8 years.
We, we started doing, uh, we started and
we came to the market when we first started as bringing
AI to continuous delivery. That was in 2018,
so be very clear, it was not generative AI. This
was predictive modeling. It was neural networks. It
was, uh, machine learning, but it
was thinking about deployments like your best engineers.
The idea here is that if I'm gonna look at the APM metrics,
if I'm gonna look at the logs,
like I don't want to have my best engineer. On the phone every
time to figure out what that should look like.
So the intention very simply, and I'll I'll show it to
you, is that as we go through this process, as you'll see,
it's gonna go through the production deployment again,
checking and validating all the critical vulnerabilities,
making sure that this is the same artifact, updating
the tickets, rolling through the database changes,
doing complex deployments like a canary,
but now it's gonna actually go verify and it's gonna look at the
things that matter to you.
So let me actually go over
here. Mhm.
Here we go.
So. Right now it's gonna
look at all the metrics that you care about. So
think about your response times, your, your error
rates, anything that you would actually consider those golden
metrics, any time series metrics, this for even,
so some of our customers, it's actually uh revenue
generation. So when I do an experiment and I wanna see if
an ad's actually giving me uh better results,
I can even use revenue as that time series metric. But
now I'm gonna go ahead and look at those and have an
understanding. This shows me that I'm slow.
If I'm slow as an engineer, the first thing I'd do is
go look at the logs,
right? And, and here's the area that, you
know, there are certain known logs that we've got, we've got exceptions
that happen, they shouldn't be there. And we'll show those
like traditionally we don't highlight them, I'll turn them on so you can
see them. But like here's an example
like this is a null pointer exception. It should not exist.
We know it shouldn't exist. However,
it's there every single time we deploy,
right? So I, if I'm, if I'm, I've been
in the system a long time, I've been with the company, I
know, OK, that, that it's OK. It shouldn't
be there but it's OK, it's fine.
We're in that same kind of concept. So what you actually
care about,
it's not about, uh, the things that we know
about it. So what about those ones that change in frequency and
what about that brand new one?
Right, that happened for the first time. Those are the signals that
we want to get to very quickly,
and based on those failures,
because Harness knows what you deployed, on
which infrastructure, with which configuration,
with which database changes, now we can actually
get you back to where you were before you started,
right? We'll go ahead, we'll kill that canary.
Alright, we'll go ahead and roll back that database change and then we'll
update the tickets and all of the systems to
make sure everyone knows exactly where we're at. We
know why we rolled back. We know where the errors are, and you can
get to what you need to.
The whole point is to solve all of those problems that
constantly take us that extra time so
we can start focusing on the things that matter to the business.
One last quick thing and then I'll, I'll, I'll let the stage
go up and, and, and, and what you're actually here for
and, and listen to Marriott.
Is all of this should be a way that it
could be a contribute uh contribution model,
right? This is not, uh, someone sitting in an ivory tower
building this very strict rigorous template
that that's the only way you can get to production. It's, it's made
so that you can actually contribute.
So even your developers, if they wanna make changes, they can commit,
uh, go ahead.
You know, give me a PR, we can go and actually merge
that and bring it into the system.
But so you can do this in the UI. You can do this as configuous
code. But the best part about this
is that now we can allow security teams, finance teams,
they can start running policies that make it very easy
for us to do the right thing but very hard for us to do
the wrong thing.
And so what I mean by that is like, let's take this whiz scan.
Oftentimes if you go look at your current CIN
CD systems,
developers will just go comment out the scan.
They'll just, the scan's taking too long, so they'll comment it
out, they'll run the build, and then they'll turn it back on. If you
don't believe me, go check your PRs. Like it's
like there's some people smiling, so trust me, that happens.
Um, you can't do that in harness. I
just deleted that whiz scan. I said, all right, I don't
want it. I'm an admin on this account. I'm a full
admin. I'm not even gonna do a PR we're gonna push
straight to Maine,
but what you'll find very quickly is I can't.
Those policies are put in place to make sure we all know
the rules of the game that we don't go and do something
wrong and and and hinder our business, so it
says you can't even save this pipeline
because it doesn't have the required security steps
that you need to go to production.
So again, all of those can be built specifically
with the context for your teams, for your
organizations, and you can have different setups for the different areas
that you have, but the whole point is to make it
extremely easy. We want everybody playing by
the same rules so we can all go faster.
Uh, I know that was a lot in a very short period of time, so
but that was a, that was just a very small subset
of what we can do, but I wanted to kind of give you some
of that AI to show you how it's truly removing
that, the worst part of the job for you to
help you then go back and do what you love.
So thank you. Yeah
So I wanted to get you a glimpse of, you know, what, uh
Harness does and how it solves these problems.
Uh, if you want to reimagine all your
DevOps, dev ops, uh, software
delivery practices now in the age of AI,
like why do you have to do so much developer toil? Why
is it all this scripting? Why is, like, you know,
it's such a mess,
it's, uh, you know, uh, we can help you through
that, uh, reimagine it all automated. All,
uh, you know, bring AI agents to it, uh,
and, uh, simplify the entire process.
So you, you'll hear from, uh, from Marriott. Uh,
so I'm going to invite, uh,
uh, you know, uh, Adnan and Sean, uh,
to join us here on the, on, on the stage
and, uh, share their journey on how they
were able to transform their DevOps and software
engineering through,
uh, you know, through,
through help of harness.
Please come on.
So let's start by, you know, everyone knows
who Marriott is. You know, I'm sure everyone has stayed in
Marriott's Hotel, but it'd be great if you can,
uh, you know,
introduce, uh, you know, each of you, uh, you,
you'll do a much better job in that, in doing
that. And like, you know, what, uh, what role
do you play at, uh, at Marriott?
Sure, do you wanna start, Sean? Sure,
I'll start. So I'm Sean Corkum, senior director
of Devset Ops and Automation.
Um,
I work within our, our DevOps
team and also our internal
developer portals to, you know, try to make our
developers' lives easier.
Uh, I'm Adnan Haq, and, uh, I
oversee our infrastructure platforms,
all our, uh,
global data centers, cloud practice,
uh, Devite cops, and, uh,
lately service reliability engineering.
And you can imagine the Marriott scale. Like, you know, Marriott
is not just one brand, it's the, you know, how
many properties you have now.
Uh, we're approaching 10,000. We,
um, we open,
including acquisition, we open about
a new property every 16 hours. Without
acquisition it's about 24 to 36
hours,
give or take 130 plus countries,
uh, yeah, 143 countries the last time I
counted. All right,
so the countries are countries are increasing
their, uh, all right,
so you know, we'll, we'll talk about.
Um, transformation when,
when any time like someone talks about any kind of transformation
starts, OK, what does transformation mean,
you know, is it, uh,
so for a company like Marriott Olivier,
you have like, you know, such a massive number of customers,
uh, consumers,
so, so much complexity
when it comes to technology, modernization,
transformation.
What does it mean?
I think that's a great question, um.
So typically it depends on
the vantage point of the person
that's looking at it, right? For
someone in the infras space,
perhaps it means looking at cloud
adoption.
Um, for someone in the application space,
perhaps it's moving from monolithic systems
to services based architecture.
Um, from a business perspective it's
about more cross-sell opportunities, more
upsell opportunities, higher revenue, right?
Um,
same thing can be said for the process
side. They're looking at processes, how to streamline
it, but to me transform transformation
is actually all of the above. They all
have to happen
at the same time.
Um,
in order for an organization
to operate.
In a manner that increases its velocity
and its ability to roll out its
products and services at a faster pace,
um, so if you really look
at the crux of what enables
that, it's moving away from the traditional
concepts of blocking governance and
bringing in technologies to automate
where the default answer is no, you
need an approval, the default answer is
yes, answer is yes, you're approved.
Unless
there's a reason not to approve it, right, automate
the approval and you know,
and the only the failure condition requires an approval,
not the normal condition.
And when you do that, you actually reduce
the cognitive overload, right?
Um, you and Nick both talked about toil,
uh, and if you look at,
um, any of the team members that are trying
to build a product,
deliver something, a service,
you know, easily 30 to 40% of their
time in a large enterprise, maybe even higher.
Uh, is the cognitive overload
of not
developing that product or service, but everything
else that has to be done, change management,
uh, approvals,
socialization, funding, managing
the budgets, etc. right?
And that's where that standardization
can actually reduce the cognitive
overload and, and that's where we are
really excited about harness because
that's exactly what it does, that's where it plays. It
reduces the cognitive
load of our
um of our team members so that they can move faster
at scale.
And that
leads us to the definition of modernization.
So what, what triggered for you guys, like,
uh, OK, let's go ahead and uh.
You know, you have old ways of doing things. You
know, what's like at some point, like, the
frustration from it builds up some for
many people it's like, you know, I'm more code coming out
with AI or something is we have, we
have to move to cloud. We have to do something
and let's, let's rethink, you know, why are we
slowing down and where the developer toil is. What, what,
what was that.
Yeah, I, I don't know if there was a single
thing, um, I think it,
uh, you know, um,
what leads an organization to transformation
is a series of things that happen,
right? When they grow fast, when the processes
stop working,
uh, when things, when the hidden factories
that were created for a purpose at one,
at one point are now just running and,
and people are are doing things just
because that's how it's been done,
right? Um, so all of that was happening,
um. The catalyst
was um.
Uh, uh, was COVID,
Marriott being a hospitality company, um,
our, our biggest challenge was going
through COVID when the hotels were literally
boarded up.
So coming out of it there was a unique opportunity
to really rethink,
um, the teams were, uh,
were reduced, uh,
significantly just to keep the lights on.
Investments obviously were difficult during
that era.
Uh, so when we started rebuilding and when
the demand actually, um,
people talked about all these.
V shaped recovery and W shaped and every
alphabet, no one talked about an Is shaped recovery.
That's what Marriott went through.
We shot through the roof. We were
trying to shut down our mainframes while we were
buying new mainframes,
so it was very interesting. So that kind of helped us
in uh really reimagining how we
want to operate as we move forward.
So with the eyes shape recovery, you have no other option. You have
to move really, really fast. You have
to do everything. You have to keep the lights on.
You can't say no to the demand that's coming
in. Uh, you have to restart
your properties and you have to rethink
how you're doing business because the old processes
were, were pretty broken at that point.
So what's, uh,
uh, how did you think about where to start?
You said, you know, you're
not moving fast enough in your innovation,
you know, or the move to digital,
um,
all the things that you need to do to, you know, in that
ice shape recovery. So how did you think
about, let's move the break the problems and
figure out where to start,
yeah, um.
So it has to start with a vision.
What is the problem that we're trying to solve? That's step
number one,
but you know, vision can only give you
so much. You have to really define it at
the right level of success criteria that
you wanna achieve,
right? Um,
and the flexibility that you need
to have,
uh, to deliver on that vision. So it's, it's all
about thinking big but delivering small,
right? Um.
Looking at areas that had the,
the, the largest blast radius and
those small levers that could
really create big waves,
right? and identifying them and
prioritizing them and I feel
that platforms is one area
where you could actually,
you know, um, where you can rethink
how a platform is operating. We, we actually
rethought how infrastructure was,
was operating and we went from becoming an
infra uh from being an infrastructure team to becoming
a platform team, right?
And we, uh, we said we're gonna build that once
we're gonna standardize it, we're gonna put
all the security control governance,
everything inside our platform so that our products
can inherit it
and as a result we're gonna reduce
the um the toil and
the cognitive load on our
engineers who are developing those products so
that they don't have to redo it.
um. It's also
really important to have
an agile mindset, and I'm not
talking about a framework like safe,
uh, scale agile framework.
I'm really talking about an agile mindset,
being a, uh, having the ability,
uh, to change course at any
point. When you see that there is
a better option, right? We can't live our
lives on shortcuts, but we should always keep an
eye
for a shortcut and if we find it, we should
be able to, um,
have that agile mindset and not
consider that as a weakness or
a problem,
but. As, as, uh,
uh, as an enablement for our teams
to make those decisions, right, and move forward,
standardization is another area where
I feel it's, it's a small,
small thing that reaps big results
once we have standardized our deployment pipelines,
right? Sean and his team
standardized the deployment pipelines.
Um, that was a pretty big impact
because now you've taken that overload, that,
that cognitive load from the
engineers.
Hundreds and thousands of engineers
by just building that one pipeline and
standardizing it.
That's the, that's the platform effect, right?
You do it once,
uh, you know, the, the move of move
from DevOps teams and, uh, infrastructure
teams to like you this is the ticket, do something
to. Yeah, give a platform
where everything's automated, standardized.
It's, it's simpler for everyone,
absolutely, and that's a big part where harness
came in for us too,
like being able to provide that, uh, it's
rich API systems that then allow
us to
create other automations and
get to the point where developers are
not having to look at a bunch of things, not having
to have that, you know,
tribal knowledge of I have to go talk to this
person for this, that person for this, submit a
ticket over here.
Uh, for us internally, uh,
they can go right to our, uh, our IDP
we call it the developer's concierge, uh,
and
that can trigger and build everything right from off
the bat. So like,
I'm starting a new product, I can just go
click I need this at microservice.
Sets them up in harness, gets them completely
configured, creates their repositories,
gets them going, and
really keeping your application developers
like writing application
code is incredibly
important
and not having to think about all these other things like
uh my security and this and that
like just.
Help take that off their plate and
just that one feature that Seann just
talked about
resulted in our time
of about 6 months to build an integrated
environment at a cost of roughly $500,000
to 35 minute self-service deployment.
Engineers can do it in the middle of the night.
Great data point, you know, that's,
that is the power of automation and standardization
and simplification. Like, you know, that's what I was, you
know, when I talk about the
impact of AI,
you know, this AI for coding and this AI for everything
after coding, and the impact of AI for
after coding could be some, could be big numbers,
and, uh, like, like this. So, you know, thanks for sharing
that. So when, when, when you guys looked at,
you know, let's go and, uh, create this
platform engineering concept and a developer
concierge.
And you started looking at tools
and the the tool chain in in in the market
has been like there's all kind of older tool chain,
you know, there's
next generation solutions like harness.
How do you guys, uh,
you know, maybe share with the people here,
uh, why did you pick harness.
So for me, kind of going through things,
uh, I've, I've gone through this rodeo
before of, of helping a, a, a
company kind of modernize the space
and
one of the big things that I've learned from that that I
wish I could go back and redo was
the fact that.
There's, you
need something that you can actually
have uh an auditable governance
around,
um, so like Nick was showing in his
demo, you know,
engineers will just, oh well that scan's
failing. I don't wanna deal with it right now, they'll remove it
and a lot of systems make it very
difficult, uh, not on purpose,
but just because of,
you know,
how they were initially architected.
To kind of uh
provide that governance
and when it came to harness having
OPA
big baked right into the platform,
now I can easily write a Rego policy
that will look across everything
and we're able to create these
templates at the account level everyone can inherit,
but they can add to
they can't take out.
There's always gonna be little quirks about their individual
applications that they'll need something
um. But they can't skip
any of these processes anymore and
we didn't have to spend
8 months writing some custom process
to build that governance around a different tool.
We had this all right off the bat.
Beyond that,
harness out of the box for us had
significant, uh, advanced
capabilities for the deployments like uh Nick had
mentioned Canary.
Doing Canary
is actually a little complicated,
uh, and we get it out of the box right
there with this.
So we were able to go from a
system that was firing forget
so you don't know if your deployment
actually succeeded, but you know
it triggered something off to Kubernetes
uh to now being able to
have it up,
make sure it's running,
watch it for however long that we want
integrated with our APM tools and
really make sure
it really is doing what we expected
and if it's not.
Let's go back
No harm, no foul to the system.
Nobody noticed. Nobody's getting paged at
3 in the morning because of it,
uh, and we're all able to, uh, to
keep moving along.
Harness was the, the only system out
there that allowed us to
really leapfrog a good 10 years
from where we were to where
I wanted to get us to
in one shot,
and that's the definition of.
Everything is approved unless it's not
right as opposed to nothing is approved
unless it is,
but that level of automation that harness
has given us has really
allowed us to implement that principle,
right, um, and then there are other
areas of course in, in the transformation,
but at least from a deployment
perspective and, uh, canary
releases and feature flags,
these are capabilities that are coming out of the box,
so. So how do
you, how do you convince the dev teams? Like one of the
things that we hear quite a lot is, uh,
you know, the platform engineering team, the leadership
team, very convinced that we gotta modernize,
uh, and automate everything,
but the dev teams are used to doing certain
things like they have CICD systems. They've,
they've used for 5 years, 10 years.
They've done some ways, and then there's a resistance
that you have to overcome. So how did you guys do that?
Uh, for us,
it, it's Adnan mentioned, we kind of followed
that agile mindset within our
space. We started small,
day one,
you know, piloting with harness as we
first started,
we started dog fooding it ourselves.
There were some teams, uh, as, you know, we
kept moving forward, some teams that were a little more
interested in, in forward thinking,
we started engaging with them. They started
getting quick wins.
So now we've got a couple of teams getting quick wins
and now their leadership
groups are seeing like, oh well this group's
delivering faster
and it can start growing organically
versus just being like a mandate
to, you know, shove down everybody's throat,
they start going, oh.
I can, I can move faster. I can
move safer. I'm not getting paid for
things as much.
I'm
able to focus more on the
thing I actually like to do in writing my
application and it starts
taking off like fire. So if you can build that
kind of excitement and
get your, your customers quick wins,
start showing it, start showing the value.
Makes it a lot easier,
yeah, you, you have to, you have to get to this
roughly 30 to 35%,
um, of mindset shift,
right? Once you have that,
I, I feel the teams build escape velocity,
then, then they just have to move forward, right? They
continue on and just rinse and repeat,
uh, and for us to reach that 35%.
Like Sean said, we had to eat our own dog
food, so we actually brought in harness to
automate the processes within the infrastructure
and platforms team.
We were still deploying infrastructure, but
everything was being done through harness.
And once we,
once we, uh,
figured out all the kinks, worked it out, and
it was working stably, that's when we started
the self-service with a few teams and we
said you can do it any time, you don't
have to depend on us
and, and, and that one piece where a
team doesn't have to depend on someone, an
engineer doesn't have to depend on someone.
That sells itself, yeah, yeah,
and engineer, that's what engineers want. They don't want
to depend on someone. They want, like, you know,
uh, they don't want to even know about
most of those things. That's not their strength. So
it's good to,
that, you know, what you, what you guys did is what, uh,
we see as a successful model because otherwise if you go
from top down and say
go and replace your things and, uh, people
just don't do it. It also helps when you can tell
your engineers, I'll have your CI time,
yes. Uh,
yeah, so yeah, let's talk about that. Like, you know, the,
the results and the numbers, uh, and I'm
sure like, you know, uh, uh, folks in the audience
would love to hear what are the outcomes of all this,
uh, what we're able to achieve. So half the build
time, yeah, so I mean for us our,
our CI time dropped from, you know, roughly
12 minutes on our old platform down
to 5,
and this guy doesn't know it, but we actually did
some tweaks about 2 weeks ago and it's, it's a little
lower. We're we're closing in on 4 minutes for CI.
Um, and how much was it before,
before it, it was 12, it was 12,
but the caveat on
that was, it was 12 but with less
things in it,
so moving into harness we've got
all of those safeguards and all those extra bits
to help start making.
Uh, things like auditability
being more automated
where teams can just go, OK, here's
a graph auditor, you got
all the information you need versus having to
do 1000 things because they only really
did like a docker build, maybe didn't even run their
tests, who knows?
They now all have that,
but we still shrunk the amount of time it took.
Yeah, the, the 12 to 5 is
all the, um, all the tweaks
that were made within harness right pre-harness
era.
Um, I, I think it's, it would be unfair
to, to, uh, judge that as a
12 minute deployment
because the amount of capabilities
that we had using Jenkins
were probably half of what we have
today. So not only did we
double the things that we're doing during
deploy deployment checks, balances,
whatever, OPA policies, etc.
we also reduced the time on top of that, right?
So, so the.
Uh, the benefit is actually significantly better
than what that metric
tells from 12 to 5.5 minutes. It
doesn't do justice.
And then going along with that too, I mean, our,
like you mentioned earlier, our, uh, environment
provisioning going down from like 6 months to,
you know, 35 minutes, 35 minutes tops,
sometimes less depending on what they need, uh.
And
trying to do that level of automation
previously with Jenkins was
very challenging to say the least.
Um, harnesses API system
make it, makes it significantly easier
for us to be able to work with that and get it going.
And uh how, how do the security
teams uh respond to this? Are they happy
that they are ecstatic that
everything is getting scanned now and
when they wanna find it and know what's going
on, they can see it all and
they know everything we're getting, you know,
like all the S-bombs, the salsa,
all the artifacts signing, all that's actually
happening.
They're like, thank you, thank you,
appreciate it. Yeah,
it's, it's, uh,
uh, the impact of modernizing, you
know, where, where you,
you automate security, security is happy and
developers are happy because they don't want to be chased by security
and, you know, did you run my scan or not
and all that stuff, yeah,
exactly, yeah, and, and once they know
that it's gonna
happen automatically.
They start removing those governance processes,
those oversights, those meetings that you have
to go to to get the I approve message
from all stakeholders,
right, change management meetings,
all of that just starts to die on the vine
by itself.
That's what I like to say like the,
the new cabin. The no cab like
your your pipeline should be the cab like you know
it's like that's everything is in
there like why do you need anything else? The automated pipeline
should be the cab and you know what it does is it actually
reduces a lot of escalations because the number of
escalations that came to me, hey, we, we need
an approval to move forward because of some.
Some fire drill some issue,
right? And, and now you're under pressure
to approve or be that
ass who's gonna say no,
go back, fix it you automate it,
you kinda remove yourself from the picture,
uh, it's the system,
you know, as,
as a,
you know, boss, the, the, the
thing that I hate the most is like someone asked me to approve something
I don't know what I'm approving.
That's a big problem. Like, you know, when you are under the fire,
like, you know, I don't under.
Should I approve it? Did you do all the right things or not? What's
the, what's the proof,
uh, and you know that's why you need all the,
you know, some process that approving instead of you approving
most of the times, yeah,
absolutely. And it, and it does it. And,
and those are not,
those weren't even the benefits that we were looking
at. Those are just benefits that you get
because you do it the right way, right? And you standardize
the processes. It's also really important
to, um.
Not automate for the sake of automation,
right? Um, a lot of times, uh,
organizations would automate toil.
That's not really good automation. Um,
you, you have to first simplify the
process. You have to make sure it's completely
streamlined and then you automate it.
Yeah, one of the things that we, um,
see in many organizations like you have 10,000 pipelines,
20,000 pipelines, uh, that are built in
Jenkins or something before.
And when people say I'm gonna move to harness, let
me bring the 10,000 pipelines from Jenkins to harness.
So that's, that's, you lose the whole point. Like
that's like you're taking the toil and the bad thing
and harness you probably need like 30 or 40
or 50, no more than that
if, if that, I think we.
Really have like less than 10
types and that builds everything we need
and like I said because of the fact that we can
provide that that level they don't have to think
it but they can add 2 for
the specific things they need.
There's no reason for all those,
and now we're, now we're, uh, taking that
same concept to
because of the scale of Marriott we, uh,
we have systems that are more centralized
in nature like our global reservation system,
right? It has to be in sync with
each and every one of those 10,000 properties
and the property management system.
So we, we started using harness,
um,
more at the, the central systems
what we call above property.
But now we're working on efforts where we're gonna
take it
to at property workloads
as well. And, and within that, maybe
the 10 goes to 20 at most,
but
with those 20 pipelines, we're going to be deploying
in 143 countries
across multiple continents
with different um
legal and policy challenges,
right? Um, whether it's China
or it's India or it's Germany or,
or, or wherever,
right? All of that built into the pipeline
just with a few patterns,
that's the power of standardization and doing it the right
way. That, that's so great to hear. That's
what we like to evangelize a lot like, you know, if
you standardize
the, um,
every app team thinks that app is very different, but
in the, in the end, like, you know, you have some patterns like 10
patterns, 20 patterns, and.
And you standardize you gain gain so much, but you
want to have the flexibility, a bit, bit of flexibility
there with the guardrails. So that's why
we had this, you know,
opine templates, but you can still go and modify,
you know, but as
you have to follow the guardrails.
Exactly, there's only so many ways to build a docker image.
Yes, yeah,
cool. So, um, let's talk about AI a
bit. You know, we are, uh, uh, it's, it's hard
not to talk about AI in the, in the world of software
engineering. So how, how are you guys thinking about AI
and, uh, how does AI
play the role, uh, in the future here
to me, so coming from my vantage point
of being in the dev ops space
and whatnot.
I think
that particular area is
so ripe for being
able to take advantage of AI,
uh, there is so much that happens
within, you know, from going from
story to production and so much
information that.
AI being able to grab that
context from what's changing in
the code to what's changing in the environment
to the tests,
being able to look at all of that and start
helping fix
the little problems that we don't wanna deal with,
that is
such a like you saw on the graph, such
a huge waste of application developers'
times and talent.
AI is, I think,
really going to take a big chunk
of that out and let them focus
more on,
you know, working with cursor Windsurf,
uh, Quiro, etc.
and Cloud code and focusing
on their applications and being able to
create amazing things
and not have to worry about, oh
my unit has failed, uh, oh I've got
a new CVE that popped up like.
Just let it,
you look at it, let it resolve, resolve
it, give you the PR so you still have a
human in the loop,
make sure it doesn't do something a little crazy
and go from there. And then
the next step from there is as that continues
to mature
and you build out better systems around
that and the models continue to get better,
you can
stop thinking about that human in the loop on that PR
and just let the pipeline handle
it because as you said, the pipeline's the new cab.
Yeah, um,
and, um,
a lot of this work people don't, uh, you know, people
are struggling to do,
you know, it's like pipelines can do a lot
of automation, but you still need to bring AI to write
the test, you know, to interpret the outcomes
of the test, you know, maybe to fix the code if something
failed, you know,
developers don't really want to do it, and, and, and
it's AI can do a better job on
many of these things now,
uh, and to create all the checks
and balances on the code coming in, you know, one
of the things that we keep hearing is the.
Just the, the code volume with AI is very
high and it's, it like
the, the same applications that used to
have a million lines of code base would
probably have for the same functionality like 2 or 3 million
lines of code base now because AI writes
a lot of code.
It can be a little verbose,
yeah, and, and it, it,
it all goes back to that earlier comment
around reducing the cognitive load,
right, and I feel,
um,
as we modernize and as we go
more towards, uh, more advanced
systems and, and ways to develop
them, um.
The the definition of cognitive load also
changes,
so unit test becomes
a cognitive load,
right? um,
uh, keeping tabs on all the different things
that have to happen starting from scratch
all of that becomes unnecessary
things
that if. We allow AI to do
that, then we, uh, uh,
then we in turn allow our engineers
to really keep their eyes on the ball
and really think about what the big picture
is, what the real value is that they need to
produce with that code, with that product, whatever
it is that they're creating,
and a lot of times
we, um,
engineers can't focus on that value.
They take their eyes off the ball because they're just
so inundated with all
these million steps that have to happen
before the value is even driven.
And and many of those things they will lose
track, you know, some balls will be dropped.
It's hard to just, you know,
uh, keep up with everything that's that's
uh that's gonna happen, the million steps.
So, what, what advice would you give to, uh,
to the audience here, if people are looking
at, uh, we have
certain ways of doing things, CICD,
uh, but we are looking at modernizing
and, and looking at harness, uh, what
advice would you give to them?
Um,
I would say particularly when you're looking to modernize
within the CICE space.
I, I said it kind of jokingly earlier
like there's only so many ways to build a docker image
really kind of keeping that in mind,
you know, standardization
will set you free
in this space
as much as any other,
so having the ability to create
a standardized template for the
various types of, uh,
applications that you'll need,
uh, it's huge. Don't drag
along the old tech debt
just let it die.
Uh, move on to the new system
and let them start seeing the, the early
wins. Find some teams in particular
that are more for, you know, forward
thinking that really wanna get,
uh, get going in this,
um, and work with them. Remember,
they're your customer.
So you need to make sure that their voice
is heard
and you're delivering them the product that they need as
well. Uh,
100% agree early wins
are extremely important.
Uh, and they get overlooked,
um, and the higher
the velocity is, the more
likely that you're gonna get some early wins.
So velocity also matters, right?
Not speed,
velocity,
right? It's a vector quantity, so
it's not the distance, it's the displacement,
right, uh, between the two points. So, so
you have to enable that somehow,
um,
and, and you have to build that escape velocity.
Once you build it, then your work is done.
The teams will take care of the rest of it, right?
Um, any leader who thinks that
it's gonna go exactly how they,
they, they thought it, um,
uh, it is, I, I would say, um,
being naive because.
Most likely it's not gonna go the way
you're thinking, right?
There's always gonna be something that's
gonna hit you sideways when you
least expect it.
And that's where it's really important to
be able to change direction as needed.
The, the agile mindset, you
know, start small,
change direction if you need to, you know,
absolutely change there because these are big changes
like the transformational
effect on software engineering is very high,
but you know people are resistant, so the
thing, the number one thing that, you know, always
amazes me is like, you know.
If you can cut down something from 6 months to
35 minutes, uh,
why, why would the organization resistant
about it, but
it's like people are sad in doing, uh, ways
to start small and, and get them there.
It's, it's changing the hearts and minds,
right? Uh, especially over the last
decade or so. Technology is no longer
the bottleneck.
Everything is possible. Anything is possible. You can
do it. Um, use harness and
everything's possible,
that too, of course,
but it's, it's really changing the, the mindset,
right? Uh,
organizations implement, uh, safe or
agile practices, but they don't implement
the agile mindset.
They implement product model,
but they don't build the level of accountability
that needs to come with product model. They will
bring in DevOps tool chain,
but they will not build, uh, bring in,
uh, uh, the.
Uh, the culture of DevOps, you build it,
you own it, soup to nuts, right? They will, they
will continue to operate in an operations
versus,
uh, project environment.
So I think changing those mindsets.
And then leveraging tools like
harness you rightfully said
to automate and standardize the processes,
really looking for those levers that
will create the big waves. Yeah,
definitely I think, uh, mindset is
extremely important. Mindset combined with the automation
and the tool chain. If you
many times like it's hard to change the mindset if you
don't give people the tool because then they say it's too hard
to achieve what I want to achieve
and then they won't change, uh, you know, change their approach
so. If you combine the two and show them the path,
you know, what, how you guys did it, like, you know, starting with
your own internal platform engineering group and
then, uh,
moving from there. That's, uh, that, that, that, that makes
sense. What advice would you give, uh,
to people about evaluating, uh, you
know, new products and tools in this space?
Um.
Keep going, always go in with an open mind.
So when you're walking around,
particularly like if you're walking around the expo here,
um. Obviously go
stop at the, the harness booth, check out the Squid Games,
uh, the theme that they have. It's quite fun,
but also, uh, wander around and, and make
sure to check in at the, the tiny booths, um,
you know, somebody that's still in a, a startup phase,
that's kind of how we
actually came across harness, uh, many years
ago at, uh, it was either this
event or the one that's, uh, or at
Cuban, uh, came across a harness
booth. You're still very early on,
but like.
That's a great idea and you kinda
keep tabs on them.
At the time, uh,
where I was, we already had a very mature
process, but
hardness always stuck in my head and when it
came to an opportunity to be able to
start anew, uh,
made a call and, uh, obviously kept going
from there.
But having a, having somebody
that's really willing to like
be your partner
in this whole process too is very
important. Changing
the entire way that
an organization
builds, deploys,
tests,
uh, is gathering audit
requirements, uh, and all of that.
It,
it's a huge deal. It's a very
tough undertaking to really kind of
make a big leapfrog, uh, uh, a
big leap in that, in that
space,
uh, so having a partner that's kind of,
you know, willing to, to, you know, go to
the wall with you and help, uh, has
been huge, and
we've had that from, from your team. I know some folks
that are here, uh, in the audience listening
as well,
and it's been great to work with and the fact that.
Especially now,
Harness has gone through it with us, we've gone through it with
many others.
It's good to have that experience to lean on too
because you can't know it all.
Yeah, a lot of, uh, a lot of large
enterprises when they're, when they're, um,
starting this, this journey, transformation
journey rely on other large
enterprises because they feel that
they can actually help them scale, right?
uh, and operate at scale,
um, but the challenge with
with dealing with a large enterprise
is that they are very set in their ways,
rightfully so because they have to standardize
as well, right?
Um,
but working with an organization that's
growing,
that's thinking, and, and more
importantly, rethinking how things are
done,
um, where you have the ability
to have a conversation and
influence their road map and product capabilities
that goes a long way because every enterprise
has these unique
areas that have to be catered
to, right?
Um, and that's where our partnership,
uh, with harness that that Marriott International
has is, is, uh,
really good because we can come and we can talk about,
hey, we have a problem
and you may not have a solution,
but you will come up with a solution and you will work
with us, right? And then that solution
goes mainstream and, and, and, and it works
with others as well. That agility
generally comes from, um,
smaller organizations that are more innovative.
And we take a lot of pride in it. And
even as we get bigger,
we set up harnesses like multiple parallel
startups so that we can retain that agility
and, you know, ability to innovate very fast
working with the working with the industry,
working with partners. So, uh,
we really appreciate the the the innovation
partnership, uh, as well.
Uh, thank you so much for, uh, for joining
us today here and uh sharing your story,
uh, and, uh, your partnership with
Harness and how we were able to help here.
I really, really appreciate it. Thank you everyone, uh,
uh, for joining us for this session today. Hope
you had a, a great conference, uh,
and, uh, uh, a good nice trip
home soon as well.
OK.